uh yeah it's uh it's gonna potentially
be pretty catastrophic is the word you
said um you know unlike consumers uh
there is no uh energy price cap for
small businesses uh and therefore we're
seeing spiraling costs uh for our
tenants for our pubs for our breweries
right across the industry you know
totally wiping out the profits they're
making uh which questions why on earth
that they would bother to open the doors
going forward
you know it's really disappointing that
the government well positive the
government supported us through the
through the pandemic um and we got
through that and we got through that in
a fairly good state
and now we're facing another crisis and
you know without further support all the
good work that happened during the
pandemic is gonna be completely unwound
so what do you need the next prime
minister to do to help you guys
it would be helpful to uh to have
somebody at the top first of all to make
some decisions uh that would be the
first uh the first step but what we're
asking for is an energy price cap for
small businesses
and we're asking for for grants to
support many of the pubs up and down the
country you'll remember when people
think about pubs you just think about
walking into a pub and having a pint but
these are also the hearts of you know
many communities uh important for the
social fabric that the uk has grown up
on and also these people it's not just
their businesses for many for many of
them it's their homes um and and whilst
they live upstairs again they do not get
the benefit of a consumer price cap um
so you know it is it is really serious
for for communities for republicans and
for small businesses
how does it compare
to uh the challenges during the pandemic
or does this just compound what you're
already seeing over the last couple of
years yeah it's been a pretty uh it's
been a pretty tough couple of years two
and a half years for the industry
um i think we came out of it pretty well
again thanks to the government's support
um we were rebuilding um you know poster
pandemic at the moment it feels like
we're
sat in the ether a bit clearly there is
no significant leadership at the top to
make decisions again you know we need
that to happen so that we can we can
have some decisions made at the moment
you know the the energy uh prices firing
we had an example uh last week uh where
one of our tenants
saw over a 400
increase
in their energy bills and it just wipes
out any profit they are making i mean as
i said before it's just just there's no
point in uh opening the doors
uh so it feels at the moment we're a bit
in the dark
and we need government to step forward
to make some decisions to support our
sector uh and keep what is a you know
what is a
cornerstone of the uk uh business
um going going over this this tough time
yes it's it's a another situation
unfortunately like the pan
[Music]
completely outside of our control